hey y'all it's conan gray and today i'm
here at buzzfeed to share my conan grey
hot takes and see how similar they are
to yours
the fans
first question is which is the best
conan grey song
maniac heather generation y or idle town
gonna have to go with heather it's just
a sad boy bop
49 heather y'all have a taste top answer
was heather with 5 000 votes
maniac has 29 with 3 000 votes then
generation y in idle count 10
heather is definitely the winner in my
heart it's my favorite song off of the
album and
the fact that it's my biggest song now
just gives me a little faith in humanity
i guess
i really love tik tok i watch a lot of
tick tocks i think my screen time on
tick tock's like three or four hours
some days
and all the heather tick tocks i quite
like i think they're
i think they're fun and creative some of
them are really depressing
but i'm like yeah true next question is
which is the best kong great video
maniac crush culture the story or wish
you were sober
oh ooh this is a hard one i know what i
like
but i think i also know what the fans
will like but i think my favorite
is probably wish you were sober i'd be
surprised if the fans picked up
wow okay so top answer was crush culture
33
i'm pretty surprised by that that video
was such
a good time to shoot but i was so
stressed out it was such a mess
second is maniac with 29 third is wish
you sober with 26
and last is the story with 12 but
they're all pretty close they're all
around like
30-ish percent which is it's good to
know that that people on average kind of
like them
thank you guys very much that means a
lot to me i think wish your server is my
favorite video
just because one it was really fun to
shoot we were on this like
little spinny wheel thing that i would
sit on the end and then like they'd spin
me around
and um it would like look like i was
like spinning through this party and
there are all these
other people um at the party they were
all like much cooler than me i remember
walking in
and being thoroughly intimidated by how
attractive everyone was
and i was like why am i here it was just
a ton of fun to shoot and
i think it turned out exactly like what
i imagined in my head so
i really liked that video which is a
superior album kid crow or
sunset season well sunset season gives
me like
violent flashbacks to my senior year of
high school it's a little stressful for
me so
um i'm gonna pick kid crow i was in a
little bit of a better mind state there
oh kid crow wins by
74 that's a good decision sunset season
got 26 percent
thanks guys i'm glad y'all like my more
recent work
next question is what's the best song on
kid crow
i mean i know what my answer is for sure
no doubt oh it has
every single song on the album is an
option this is going to be divisive guys
so comfort crowd wishes over maniac
online love checkmate
the cut that always leads fight or
flight affluenza can leave your friends
heather
little league the story you already know
i feel like everyone already knows that
my favorite song off of the album is
heather
so i'm gonna pick heaven i worked so
hard on it it was so personal it was
like such a horrible
moment in my life and the fact that
people appreciate it
just makes me happy so i'm gonna pick
heather
heather wins with 36 percent oh look at
that
second place is maniac with 15 then
third places wished you were sober
that's actually kind of surprising
the least popular the least popular
song of the album is the interlude can
we be friends
noted i guess y'all don't want to be
friends whatever which taylor swift song
should conan cover the options are exile
last kiss holy ground all too well
enchanted such wildest dreams mash up
i've never i don't know if i've seen
that uh or sad beautiful tragic
you're really asking a lot out of me to
make me decide on this
i'm gonna pick all too well because it's
a classic
and he called me up again just to break
me like a promise so casually cruel in
the name of being honest
who can come up with those lyrics only
taylor swift okay i'm gonna click it
maybe this might be what people like i
don't know ah
wow okay so the top answer was enchanted
slash follow the strings
match up enchanted is a great song
the first verse or just like that was so
good i've actually been listening to a
change a lot lately
and of course i mean wildest dreams that
music video
just throw me into the safari my top
three songs off of folklore
i really like the one and also invisible
string i'm like thinking about them
they're like i like literally want to
cry thinking about it
you know what i really think cardigan is
a
just a beautiful beautiful song i love
love love love love
mirror ball and seven and the whole
entire album but
i go back to cardigan a lot just because
i love all the references she makes to
her own career and i love
just the way that that song feels and
you know yeah there is this thing when
you're young you get
kind of underestimated but i think we as
humans should like really learn to trust
our gut because like we do know when
someone is good or when someone is bad
i love cardigan a lot but invisible
string is probably my most played
because i'm definitely the type of
person that's like oh maybe somewhere
out there
in the city there's like one person and
they're working in a cafe right now
but in two years we're gonna meet and
we're gonna have children
who should conan collaborate with billy
love you billy
taylor frank ocean and alicia keys
pretty sure
i know what people are gonna say so i'm
gonna go with taylor
i love you billy you are just my sweet
baby and i love you
but i'm gonna go with taylor oh my gosh
wow whoa
i just shocked myself for a second
taylor and billy
are in basically a tie but billy won by
20 votes wow would absolutely die to do
us on with philly i love her
so much i just feel like i have such a
long history of
simping for taylor swift i love you
billy what's the superior conan great
tweet
first option is i'm tired of being tired
imagine being in love
i'm gonna vomit yeah i mean that's
disgusting
just be like i'm fine then streaming
ribs by lord while laying in bed wishing
they'd never aged past 13 because it
feels so scary getting old and this
dream isn't feeling sweet i'm [ __ ]
and the last one is sadly i am human i
have no i have
no idea i think i'm going to go with
imagine being in love i'm going to vomit
but also i think maybe this be like i'm
fine then stream rips by the lord might
be
a close one as well because oh i'm going
to go with ribs by lord you know i'm
going to go with ribs my lord because
ribs by lord is a lifestyle not a song
my brain is so big ribs by lord wins
with 46 then second place imagine being
in love i'm gonna vomit
god i'm just so my brain is so fat and
sexy
the last question is what is conan's
best
look spelled l-e-w-k skirt chic
hair clip moment pavement ponder it's me
sitting on the ground
because i'm a piece of trash and last is
checkerboard king
i think i'm gonna go with skirt chic i
feel like it was um
it was something that had to be done it
was something that that i deserved i
deserved to be in a skirt
yep skirt chic wins 33 then pavement
ponder
second place interesting i was i'm
surprised by that i guess they love when
i sit on the ground
all right that was all the questions uh
you can listen to my album kid crow it's
out everywhere
thank you guys for all of the support on
heather thanks for watching